los combates se están centrando en la
zona industrial de ese veredones que
donde ahora mismo se parapetan las
fuerzas ucranianas y donde hay cientos
de civiles intentando resguardarse de
esos bombardeos en la planta química de
azov el gobernador regional ha señalado
también que la vecina lis y chance la
situación ahora es muy preocupante en la
estrategia del ejército ruso continúa
siendo la misma que hemos visto durante
toda esta invasión rusa que en ucrania
bombardean por completo ciudades las
destrozan hasta que pueden avanzar de
forma terrestre pero no hay un avance
significativo de las tropas rusas en las
últimas horas lo único que podemos
confirmar es el bombardeo continuo de
esa zona del donbass el propio
presidente cell entes que ha vuelto a
insistir en la gravedad de lo que está
ocurriendo en la batalla del donbass y
ha dicho que a rusia sólo se le puede
ganar en el terreno de batalla porque
está bombardeando también zonas como en
la que nos encontramos en kharkiv se
están intentando acercar a la ciudad en
estos momentos están a tan solo 20
kilómetros pero intentan lanzar un
ataque para volver a
jarquín la segunda ciudad más importante
de este país en nuevo frente de batalla